Marines are without a doubt one of the
single most powerful groups of fighters
in all of One Piece so we're going to
rank the 15 absolute strongest Marines
in the entire story and we cannot start
this list without including the very
first person to ever truly defeat Luffy
on his quest to become Pirate's King
this chain smoking fiercely loyal Marine
is vice admiral smoker who was always
set up as Luffy's Main Marine rival from
the very start of the story and besides
effortlessly overpowering Luffy at the
start of the story he has grown strong
enough to even fight on equal footing
with a warlord of the sea you know
what's even cooler Smokers smoke devil
fruit Powers were the very first Loki
ability we ever came across in the story
plus I cannot imagine that he's done
climbing the ranks of the Marines
because after Anis Lobby he basically
just decided it was time to stop messing
around and soon after he was promoted to
vice admiral which is one of the reasons
I'm totally convinced that by the end of
this crazy story he'll be one of the
strongest new generation around however
while smokers On The Rise he still pales
in comparison to the jaw-dropping feat
of Vice Captain tsuru and that's because
suru is simply a legend in the Marines
whose reputation is on par with some of
the strongest Marines in history
including many of those who are coming
up at the top of this list in fact she
is so well respected that even the foul
mouth doflamingo cannot help show her
some sort of respect and while her wash
devil fruit isn't the strongest she is
absolutely one of the most extraordinary
tacticians in the entire Marines and she
undoubtedly played a pivotal role in
developing the battle plan during the
Epic War Marine Fort and I cannot wait
to talk about all the insane Marine
fighters who actually took part in this
war but before that it's really
important to keep the Japanese original
in mind with stuff like this because a
lot of nuance can actually get lost
depending on the translation those are
really the only way to be 100 sure
what's being set here would be to
actually learn Japanese which guess does
take a lot of dedication discipline but
if you really want to be able to read
Mong and watch anime in Japanese like me
using today's partner Rosetta Stone
makes it easier than ever to actually
learn a new language in case you don't
know in their courses they make sure to
base their lessons on immersion and
language that you can actually use in
everyday life plus I really like that
they added this great voice recognition
tool that makes sure that you also
develop a natural accent which is
something that I wish I had when I was
studying Japanese and so since I want
you to be able to enjoy one piece to 100
in a draw form as well I strongly
recommend that you try their Japanese
course but I would also be more than
happy if you picked up my native
language German for instance since they
have Over 20 Languages to choose from if
you want to learn more than one language
I've partnered up with Rosetta Stone for
an exclusive 50 discount on their
lifetime subscription for 150 instead of
300 which gives you exclusive access to
all the languages for life we have the
self-proclaimed best defender in the
world sento Maru now this Sumo inspired
character is the ultimate bodyguard of
the world government's genius scientist
Dr vegapunk he's a truly powerful
fighter who even showed off the first
use of advanced armament hockey in the
story before haki was even introduced
but you know what's even crazier his
true power lies as the commander of the
Marine Science unit which includes the
Cyborg pasifista and the Genetically
Enhanced seraphim clones as well like
seriously anyone who can control these
mind-boggling powers can basically win
entire Wars all on their own however
while centomaro eventually got washed by
these Relentless government agents this
next Marine put up a way tougher fight
against the same enemies and honestly
for the longest time we didn't even know
that Diaz Drake better known as X Drake
was actually a marine and that's because
he was actually a secret undercover
agent working for the secret Marine
organization sword and let me tell you
this man is an absolute monster
literally who became a world famous
pirate equal to pre-time skip he's an
incredible fighter who dual wields this
impressive ax and a sword and can also
turn into this enormously powerful
dinosaur with his Allosaurus devil fruit
and to top it all off he got so strong
that he actually became one of the yonko
kaido's top officers before flipping
sides and helping turn the tides during
the battle on onigashima however Drake
isn't even the strongest secret Marine
in sword and that's because at number 11
we have the character who might very
well be the strongest Marine ever by the
time he reaches his full power that's
right this right here is the future
Fleet Admiral but I'm being honest while
Kobe started out as a pretty pitiful
weakling his growth rate in the story is
simply ridiculous I mean he went from
being this crying little kid to an
absolute chat in just a few years and at
this point can even stand up to yonko
Cruz like blackbeards without backing
down and while he doesn't have a devil
fruit yet at least he's a master of
observation hockey seems to show hints
of conquerors hockey and I wouldn't be
surprised if he eventually became the
strongest Marine ever however he'll have
to wait to climb the Marine ranks which
is also the sad fate for these two
marines right here and you may have even
forgotten that Gian and tokikage
actually exist and we certainly don't
have any impressive feeds for them but
these two Vice Admirals were
specifically mentioned as candidates to
take the two vacant Admiral spots during
the time skit which even though we know
barely anything about them must mean
that they are incredibly strong if they
barely missed the cuts to be considered
at the same level as these next Marines
in the ranking because this brings us to
the incredibly hyped admiraltier which
has always been portrayed as absurdly
more powerful than your everyday marine
and at the bottom of the Admiral tier is
the meme the myth the legend Admiral
greenball and even though he's
constantly made fun of for being scared
of Shanks and being in a kainu fanboy he
is undoubtedly still very much powerful
with his far first logia devil fruit
which he can actually use to grow deadly
Vines and giant forests in the blink of
an eye and in fact he even took on the
entire guardians of wano and easily
fought the commanders of the
Revolutionary Army and the man fighting
right beside him or ironically sometimes
against him in the clash with the
Revolutionary is the blind Admiral
fujitora however don't be fooled by him
not being able to see because this man
will straight up drop a meteor on your
head with his gravity devil fruit powers
and this devil fruit is one of the truly
most OP powers in one piece which is why
it only barely missed the cut for my top
5 devil fruit ranking for example
fujitora can use its powers to fly
effortly Crush opponents lift giant
heaps of rubble and combine gravity with
his sword to create devastating attacks
put this on top of his observation
hockey which is so strong that he can
basically see by sensing the people
around him however his strength isn't
even the most important part of his
character because fujitora is also a man
on a mission to rid the Marines and
world government of corruption he
frequently disobeys orders that he
doesn't think are good and he even
desperately worked to disband the entire
warlord system after he saw what
doflamingo did to the country of
dressrosa and unlike the next Marine on
this tier list if you want to stay free
of world government corruption make sure
to subscribe to the channel for more one
piece content just like this because
unfortunately for this former Marine
Admiral he never had that opportunity
because he left the Marines after his
crew was completely wiped out and the
government didn't care at all and while
you might rightfully say that Zephyr
never officially actually appeared in
the manga he is the main antagonist of
Film Z although it is basically
confirmed that his backstory is actually
Canon and that's because during his time
as a marine he became a famous trainer
who brought up many of the Marine
Prodigy still to come on this list and
with everything we see in this film he
certainly is a devastatingly powerful
fighter on par with many of the most
legendary older generations of the
Marines Sapphire mainly brawls with his
fists including his super destructive
mechanical arm and is a master of haki
and the dokushiki techniques as well
though even this overpowered Master
eventually got taken out by his student
because Admiral kizaru showed up at the
end of Film Z and wiped out his former
teacher however don't feel bad for safer
because kizaru is also a true weapon of
Destruction who might actually own the
title of defeating the most pirates in
the entire story this user of the light
food can kick at light speed and shoot
out incredibly powerful beams of Light
which he used to almost take out the
entire worst generation of pirates back
on Saba ODI and honestly I would love to
have even a fraction of this man's
confidence because he straight up waited
to go tuano to take care of big mom and
kaido by himself like what a Madman is
lad he's also the only Marine to remain
an admiral both before and after the
time Skip and is undoubtedly going to
play a major role in the future of the
story including on Egghead Island which
is also coincidentally precisely what
we're all hoping for Kong who could
either be the strongest Marine in
history or just some random side dude
who loves his oversized fish tank in his
office and while that second option is
highly unlikely because he used to be
the fleet Admiral before sengoku I mean
come on can we get any remarkable Feats
for this man I even considered putting
him much lower in my ranking because
even I sometimes forget about this dude
in the first place because he has done
literally nothing in the story despite
his impressive resume that's because
what we do know for a fact is that he's
the current world government
commander-in-chief who has complete
control of both the Marines and Cypher
pole agencies plus he was the fleet
Admiral during Rogers era so we should
expect him to be strong since the fleet
Admiral is promoted from the Admirals
and you only get to that point being
Ultra super strong and I mean also he's
one of the buffest looking dudes in the
entire story but that cloud can only
take him that far and maybe the only
time that we ever saw kongad actually
angry was when the next Marine on this
list turned in his resignation and it
may surprise you that I have ranked
sengoku over Kong but in my opinion
sengoku has always been massively
underrated just because he gets
overshadowed by the number one figure on
this list however this Afroman was the
former Fleet Admiral for a reason he
fought against Whitebeard and Roger in
their primes he is a great tactician who
was smart enough to outmaneuver white
bedroom Marine Ford plus he has the
Golden Buddha legendary devil fruit
which can send out giant shock waves and
has always stood out to me as something
that might have some other super secret
powers that we have yet to see in the
story which I know is kind of hard to
believe but you will probably be even
more shocked by who is ranked above
sengoku on this list and that's because
next up is aokiji the ice fruit logia
user and while he may not be a marine
anymore after joining the Blackbeard
Pirates we just have to include him here
because of the possibility that he might
be working undercover and this man is an
absolute God his devil fruit powers are
so op that he nearly wiped out the straw
hat crew after Skype here he can easily
fight on par with the yonko and even a
super powerful character like though
Flamingo did not want to mess around
with him and what's even more impressive
is that he fought for 10 whole days
against the kainu who's our next
strongest Marine in my ranking and this
epic Clash of ice and the kainu's magma
these two literally changed the terrain
of an entire Island however as you know
Akino eventually won this legendary
Clash so we just have to rank him
slightly higher here and it is fully
deserved as he is what the author called
one of the most destructive powers in
the entire story with his makma devil
fruit I mean this power is literally so
strong that the kainu could literally
punch off half of whitebeard's head
along with a ton of other very
impressive accomplishments a Kino is the
current Fleet Admiral and just has to be
one of the final antagonists of the
entire story which is honestly insane
that there is another even more powerful
Marine but I simply could not rank this
one any lower he was the Rival of Goldie
Roger took out Roxy's back and even
wanted to kill akinu himself during the
war at Marine Forts and I'm of course
talking about Monkey D GARP and we see
just how insanely powerful he is in the
recent chapters when this old Garb who
is not even in his prime anymore
basically wiped out half of a yonko's
crew plus an admiral level character by
himself and used his Advanced conquerors
hockey to destroy the entire town with a
single punch and while this particular
moment showed off garp's ridiculous
power because it happened so recently it
didn't make the cut for my top 13
conquer hockey moments in the story but
if you want to see which legendary
moments did make the list you can watch
that video right here thanks for
watching and I'll see you in the next
one